this year the sheen of success has worn
off forgiving people and people talking
about crisis yet a lot of the people who
were here were part of the group that
created the crisis so it needs to be a
much broader debate on the issues that
are here this is a very important how do
we bring prosperity back but also how do
we ensure that growth is that you shared
more evening because this crisis
economic crisis is going to hit the
poorest most vulnerable in society in
the worst possible way so what do the
rich you have how do they make sure that
those who are on the fringe society the
ones will have been excluded are
actually brought into the debate because
unless that is done social cohesion will
affect instability and insecurity become
more prominent issues are in this year
and that has to be not only about
stability growth diverse this economic
forum focus about creating a possible
but we still in crisis we need a much
broader debate with all stakeholders and
many of them out here